[Music]
[Music]
feels like I've been walking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning trust the Millennial morning
show your two best friends Jackie O and
cloudy here hi you there and how you
doin money on I was just up so late
watching the video music awards it was
just such a long night me at the
after-party with Tyler and Teller and
Gigi and Bella I have so many thoughts
about the award show but first of all
I've never felt closer to my fellow
Millennials because they've never felt
older than I did last night
um usually I find that that's the case
that a lot of award shows especially MTV
who like try so hard to be cool but I
found that I knew mostly all of the
talent no there was straight like yes
there are some people that I don't
participate in their music that's fine
I'm a little a shot but there were some
people that I showed up had never heard
of and that's when you know well so
people are you talking about people at
the award show giving out awards and
getting awards or the people on the red
carpet performers there were performers
that I had never heard of who um Rosalia
I'd never heard of her before but I'm
glad to have what an incredible talent
and there was so much talent on a spike
and um I can't wait to go into it
normally I stand every bad thing we've
ever said on the show I take that she's
my queen I don't you go he just doesn't
do the gymnastics no no this would think
she's such a good dancer but she was
like she wasn't singing okay yeah she's
an amazing dancer she's a dancer she's
into sick everything she should be on
honestly like she should be like the
next Julianne Hough she's a sick
everything cuz like seeing it for her
anyway this songs not that good was good
her outfit was so cute the dancing was
spectacular and they couldn't get the
costume up I was gonna kill someone but
I just don't get like the whole normanni
stand shoot and people act like she's
the second coming of Christ
wow I thought today like he would find
like you've said that before that you
don't get the norm on East attitude and
I thought you know you come on this show
and be like we got it because I fully
got it no I don't get it at all I was
literally watching her I was like it was
incredible yeah it was a performance it
was a great but she's no singer no I get
it
don't get me wrong I get why the Stata
to die get my people really I don't it
was her but I just don't Margo is her
first performance as a single artist
ever so it's like she has this whole
Stata tude not
yes that's what she said at the VMAs
maybe but no she literally said on the
to Terrence J yeah who's our first solo
performance she's done it with love lies
she always has someone with her yeah so
it's her first solo performance ever and
she's the second coming of Christ and
she has it haven't even released a song
because they saw something in her you've
never liked you know bed on a horse that
was just like up and coming well yes I
bet on a horse out of fifth harmony and
it was coming like a Baio and that horse
is paying off in you think so that horse
is getting drunk at every award show oh
my god no oh my god when she screams get
wasted when they when she accepted her
award because that he was trunk she
shrunk at the award show look out for it
I would be too
no it's it's a little boy everyone was
drunk last night when Gigi and Bella
went up to read for Rosalie I was like
how are they gonna talk because they
were drinking all night it's just it's a
part of being a celebrity if to learn
how to read and be drunk it's something
I can look like Camila caballo is drunk
at every single award show and she's
like performing she's working like Gigi
but it never had extra voice she's
littering out of everyone they're the
only one who didn't sing with a bat
check and the only one that actually
sounds a decent I okay disagree
can we look about you sound amazing yes
I'm sorry Liz oh is in a stratosphere of
her own so I don't like I don't compare
her to like the plebeians on earth
because she's extraterrestrial yeah no
anyways we're gonna we have all of the
VMI's but it was just interesting like I
really felt cultured like I know what's
going on with you the zoo
I'm just like this not Julie was a you
guys trying crazy they're off tobacco
there aren't willing and honestly it's I
understand cuz it's like teens aren't
smoking cigarettes I didn't ever
understood like why they were so
hell-bent on Marshalls we're getting
today I'm not gonna leave her I'm a lab
rat we don't know the long-term effects
of Julie so we are just lab rats like
they're testing it on us and the lab
rats are laughing at us yeah the lab
rats are protesting for us whereas we
usually have to produce for the various
coercion we are bruisers bill right yeah
it's just something that we got to me
too I have mine my Hindu they literally
like throw it across there I was like
yeah I know it was
really like it was getting to me um okay
like I feel like nothing else happened
yesterday because all I did was watch to
be amazed like they were on for six
hours
yeah David started it safe and ended
when I wasn't the interesting they had
like a really [ __ ] up red carpet like
the red carpet opened for like people to
come at 6:00 Taylor was there at 6:00
but their stream on MTV didn't start
till 7:00 so like they miss so much it
was half pre-recorded half live but I
found a live stream on Twitter of like a
paparazzi camera just literally like in
the paparazzi image with everyone and
you got to see like all the intricacies
of like the awkward celebrity moments on
the red carpet like the entire cast of
Jersey Shore showed up but Snooki had
already walked the carpet by herself so
they couldn't take pictures until she
came so they were all waiting for her
before they shoot but they could come
and then Dina wanted to take solo
pictures Tina had to go all the way
around to do it again she came back by
20 minutes later it was very inefficient
the whole thing there was a lot of
issues I mean for me the biggest was
like justice for Taylor Swift because
the cameraman did her dirty it was
either he was zoomed in on her face
during her performance are so wide I was
shaking that was really [ __ ] too
it was the most poorly produced award
show I've ever seen because on more than
one occasion first of all audio went out
some cameraman like dropped his camera
yep to the cameraman was drinking with
Camilla Kanaya
yeah no it was so for Klimt and I get
why they kept going wide for Taylor
because she had all those effects that
you could only see on TV but like we
didn't see her like her her body once
like I couldn't it was she was out there
so far or up her nose no I know and it's
like I want to see her and a few others
maybe like some legs and medium angles I
don't know I'm not a camera person but
it just doesn't seem like that hard yes
so they took them awhile to get their
[ __ ] together I really really
appreciated how everyone was just so
confused about the fact that it was in
New Jersey oh my god yeah especially
Diplo I scanned it blow so hard I said
oh his interview was hilarious to blow
hilarious when he was like it's great to
be in Newark like I haven't been here
since idea yeah so does it get gas on my
way through the city and then he was
like all my fans together because it was
just so funny and what was he doing
there because I guess you must nominate
nominate but like usually if you're
nominated and you show up like it's
gonna win something right except for the
case of the Jonas Brothers who literally
got passed up for every award except for
the last one yeah album but they want
something they had
Gorman's it was New Jersey and that's
what they have to like now they're part
of the machine like they have to do all
this [ __ ] yeah there are people who
don't have to know like ariana grande
baby show up yeah but Jonas Brothers
like how are you
Ron gate refuses I went to the VMAs last
year and I remember it was literally
already Grande's Bat Mitzvah like she
won all the awards everyone was thinking
or talking about her like she was
bopping around the stage with her
ponytail like it was obviously her award
show this one was obviously Taylor's
like VMAs like allies himself to one pop
queen per year and then they make it
like their year where they can like act
like it's their about Mitzvah yeah
because Taylor Swift isn't gonna show up
if she's losing every award tell Ariana
Grande and already got any stock in the
shop if she's losing every reward to
Taylor Swift yeah so it's kind of
annoying because the awards really feel
so meaningless meaningless so it's like
you definitely know when you're gonna
win and it's just not an accomplishment
no I'd completely forgot that there were
awards going on because there was like
you know live comedy from Sebastian
Maniscalco there were performances I was
just like fixated I'm watching
celebrities like mingled with each other
I literally forgot that like people
showed up there like get awards yeah but
I want to talk about the whole thing so
that is our first story so I think
without further ado it is time for the
satisfied stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast which I really
need to say because I'm starving
well I wouldn't I would be remiss and I
would be so heartbroken if I didn't
mention the fact that your jugs are in
my face right now
I know I don't know what to do which is
perfect because today's episode is
brought to you by 3rd love honestly this
is a great endorsement person third love
because I freaking need a bra today your
jugs are just beautiful so they could
really benefit from the carrying handle
from the setup up a third level third
love bra we just moving that third love
on the show for a while it has truly
changed my life I got of all the brands
that we speak about this one that's hard
the most positive impact on my back on
my breasts and on my neck I'm third love
is a your overall silhouette yeah it is
the most inclusive bra company basically
you go online I feel like a lot of
people don't know what size bra they
actually are they've just been wearing
the same one from the department store
like since they were 16 but you take a
quiz and ask you a bunch of questions
about your current précised your
overflow your cuppage your wire a bunch
of questions and then
I have this magical quiz that tells you
your exact bra size over 12 million
million women have taken the quiz to
date it's actually fun and takes less
than a minute to complete did you know
that breast shape matters when finding a
good fit I have a bell shape if anyone
is curious their love helps you identify
your breast size and shape and find
styles that fit your body they have a
perfect fit promise every customer has
60 days to wear it wash it put it to the
test and if you don't love it return it
and third level wash it and donate to it
donate it to a woman in need love that
their loves team of expert fit stylists
are dedicated to helping you find your
perfect fit fit stylists are available
every day to help via text chat or phone
their love knows there's a perfect bra
for everyone so right now they're
offering our listeners 15% off your
first order go to 3rd love.com slash
morning toast now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 15% off your first
purchase
that's third love thi Rd l.o.v.e comm
slash morning toast for 15% off today
just do it like yeah I don't need a
catchy slogan it's the most important
thing is your bra yeah it's it's time
for third law and if you only get one in
a class you for like six years
if you never watch it's like that's what
I do totally okay Nia Mays let's take it
from the top red carpet cluster [ __ ]
cluster [ __ ] and I didn't know if I just
looked like a [ __ ] to me because
I was watching this like behind the
scenes but also because like we're hosts
writing like seeing every time sir
Larsen was that that was hard through
her and you know what keep girl but what
is she hosting she's yeah you're like
that's like making putting Taylor Swift
to work on the carpet like no I couldn't
agree more
I love Zara Larsson I think she's one of
the most underrated like vocalists of
her generation she has the most the most
amazing music like every song I'm like
this song is a [ __ ] bigger Sarah
Larsson sings it what's that song that
she sings really best symphony I just
wanna I don't understand the decision
here I think that was like a real like a
huge step down for her but I'm sure like
her and her team thought about is this
huge opportunity and obviously she did
do a great job because she's not a
[ __ ] host she's a singer and she was
like being put in these really awkward
positions and I just I was really
painful to watch and perhaps the most
painful conversation to watch was her
talking to Sebastian Maniscalco oh my
god it was awful I need to get your
thoughts on smashing Maniscalco I just
want to say once again Terrence J is the
host
generation he really put that you know
who's really coming in like as i
giuliana rancic to his ryan seacrest
Nessa
I totally she is so [ __ ] good at her
job like MTV like really invested in her
from the get like from girl code like
she has been MTV like she goes to the
toilet on the after show and she is
worthy like she is [ __ ] good at her
job
I agree and they also put her in the
worst situations like could there have
been more sponsors like t-mobile mister
that announced an award right now while
the fans have to put up their things
also you're gonna find out right now
you're going to the show like she
literally is like they're just making
her [ __ ] dan it's like it's like a
puppet and it's so what like any other
host it's so uncomfortable she does the
best in those types of guys but they
really like make her do they make her
work for her money
they do I couldn't I just there were so
many [ __ ] sponsors every minute was
sponsored Aiko extra Pepsi Pepsi
t-mobile there was some sort of race it
was real some sort of Taco Bell the new
artist award
yes sponsored by Taco Bell I don't know
so they played the same for commercials
everything works to break and I get it
that it's a sponsor but I can't see the
same thing okay but I wasn't hating that
Amazon music commercial for Taylor
because me very the most beautiful like
the pregnant commercial the clear blue
if I saw that was the one for the pill
that you take I think it's HIV
prevention oh yes but then it's also
like if you listen to the rest of the
commercial it's like doesn't fully
prevent against HIV it's like does
nothing actually if you listen to all
the fine print
okay so the red carpet was so complete
and utter [ __ ] show and by the way you
know what's so funny is I checked my
time up this morning and we were
watching the VMAs two years ago in
Atlantis do you remember that where we
were like dying at that girl yes Gabi
Gabi gay and it came up in my Instagram
choice and I was three years have gone
by three VMAs and mtv cannot find a good
host why that was three years ago that I
got alcohol poisoning in the Bahamas yes
we were drunk watching the VMAs and this
girl was just like she could have put
two words together yeah and people
buckle under pressure like to give
someone a first-time hosting gig on the
VMA or carpet is a huge mistake like
people think it's so easy just to talk
it's impossible to just talk to people
like when it's your job to carry on the
conversation and ask them questions also
hot tea I think
be easier to host the Oscars because
it's just passing through pipes like a
template of who are you here for a world
are you wearing the VMAs there's so much
going on there's so many stages there's
so many sponsors there's so many people
doing different things here that they
have to promote that it's like a noob
can't can't comp my comprendo love that
well so let's talk about Sebastian
Maniscalco because there has been like
an overwhelmingly negative reaction Tim
but but by the way even if he did the
most amazing job like top ten out of ten
people always find a way to hate the
host so no one ever says the host was
amazing it was always bad so I hope he's
reading the reviews like with that in
mind and I felt really bad because I
really wanted him to like be happy and
like be doing a good job because I
thought it was I really thought it was a
good choice like someone who's not so
much like a part of pop culture but kind
of comments on it but I do think he was
just like a little too out of touch like
he doesn't talk about pop culture and
his stand-up he doesn't know who the
Jonas Brothers are you know what I mean
I think he was like a little too out of
the scope of what they of what was going
on to be a good host yeah also I guess
hey shake and you guys really like him I
do I do I don't which is weird cuz we
like all of the same things and when we
saw him perform at Robin Hood like I was
actually excited because I was like oh
oh you know get agent Robin Hood changed
me on Michael che and Colin Jost Colin
Jost and I just didn't I didn't get the
alert at all
so when watching him last night like he
doesn't do it for me at all so he was
like making fun of the people who are in
the room you know I thought he was doing
a good job of like up sidestepping like
he wasn't making fun of of anyone not
the artists he had spent a generation of
people who are in the real see that was
that was their mistake
I think they chose him so that he would
play to the Jersey people in the room
not the millions of people watching just
like this 10,000 people who were
actually there because those are like
Jersey people that he's very you know
Journal you know I was the complete
opposite it's like he'll play to the
people at home who are like yeah all
these people are in the audience on
their phones MTV has cameras like
they're gonna capture it don't worry he
was like making fun of the people in the
rooms for the people at home but it's
like the people in the room are who you
need to laugh at your joke no but it's
the exact opposite like but no one was
like Jackie I agree with you know when
you're doing that the the the audience
is but where were we Oh Amazon Prime
literally not a single per
in that concert was listening to Jane
Lynch she was doing it for the people on
screen like I think whatever they were
writing was meant for the people at home
not for the people audience and that was
the mistake I think they made like his
Josie shtick like you don't get it
unless you're from Jersey and the people
in Prudential Center were from Jersey I
think the people at home like weren't
even getting him at all like his like
his accent and he's like mannerisms and
just his physicality which i think is
super funny just doesn't translate like
on a national scale I don't even think
everyone in the room is from Jersey cuz
like people flew in in shape for it like
every time anyone said like New Jersey
Devils nobody screamed no seat fillers
are from New Jersey I don't think so in
the world like so true we went to the
VMAs and I now I say something lunchbox
I have flashbacks I see it with the
whole new lens like the seat fillers you
guys you don't understand the industry
that like that's cropping up it was a
sea sea world so I don't think they're
all from New Jersey because their seat
seat they're gonna find might be from
New York no I don't think they're flying
in from out of state like I think that
that they're definitely from the
tri-state area I think Sebastian
Maniscalco was a good was a good choice
if this wasn't a televised event I think
it's the exact opposite I think the
people at home got it the people in
there did not I was giggling and yeah
you're at every single reaction but I
really was like rooting for him like I
it was like it was wholesome like family
fun like every single reaction I saw on
Twitter was negative Hey Twitter is it a
generally negative place but I think the
over walk overwhelming consensus
consensus from people at home was that
it wasn't good and like who is this
person right well that was the other
thing like he's so well known but if you
don't know him like you have no idea
cause he doesn't do movies like he's
just stand up I feel as though he's
really big
internationally right isn't that how you
heard of him from your friends know that
Scott O'Malley huh okay where did he
come from sniffles he just really had a
bunch of Netflix specials and he's okay
super popular stand-up like he sells out
huge anywhere if he succeeded if she
succeeded at the VMAs it would have
opened him up to a whole new audience
like that and it would have an
instantaneous and everyone up loved him
and it was a huge leap for him to do
that and it didn't land no attendant
lands but I don't know whose fault it
was that I didn't land I just don't
think it was a good pairing no me
neither you want to know why I feel like
he's very set in his like comedy ways
and like
just wants to tell the same types of
jokes but he I don't know if he was
willing to like be a chameleon and like
change his shtick and his content and
like his voice for the new platform he
was back and maybe the audience like
just didn't understand like the whole
triggering thing people on Twitter got
mad but it's like yes audience if he did
that right maybe thinking it was funny
but like so lights can't it just it
really is reminding me that I'm Sondheim
concert because Jane Lynch was working
so [ __ ] hard at the Amazon Prime
concert like she was hosting and we I
didn't watch it live on prime but like
there was a whole story being told like
her and Tyler Oakley where the host and
homegirl she practiced the entrance for
any time she was working so hard people
were being so loud gonna get bad like
she was doing standing up literally to
the camera while the microphone was
fully playing in in the theatre but not
a person was listening it is probably
the hardest job she was pretending like
everyone there was like with her hahaha
that's the hardest job and I feel like
he was getting immediate when your
comedian like you were used to immediate
laughs being like oh that was good joke
because people laughed I heard people
laugh I can move on but he wasn't
getting that instant gratification and I
think that really threw him off oh yeah
he was cirno's you have to be a true
professional like I will never not have
the most respect for Jane Lynch after
watching her at the Amazon Prime concert
literally working so hard with these
terrible jokes that were written for her
by like TV writers and not a soul was
listening and not a soul was laughing
yeah yeah understood okay so overall I
didn't totally mind it I don't think
that it I don't think they would
consider it a success nobody will be
invited back no but I do like live for
you know I'm should be going down the
comic rau you know maybe now they're
looking for younger comedian who would
like knows a little bit more about pop
culture and like has a morning chat I
think you'd be perfect for it I know and
you know everyone's treating me like I
love that you should have been you and I
just totally agree with them totally
great or you interns J like yes you know
what support he would crush it
sometimes they overthink a host like
there wasn't even that much involved in
being host specially - Cal came on TV
like six times like and he wasn't he
made one joke each time like 10 shake
could do that like maybe let's stop
overthinking and and just leave a host a
host exactly okay then Taylor opened yes
oh my god um just how did you feel I
would I'm not glad I was not into those
like word effects that they kept sue me
out for like it was cool the first time
but then it kept getting it felt stupid
mhm but her outfit was amazing living
for Terrance not Terrance
todrick being her backup dancer then
like that that from the high to like the
like the the anthem that loud the dance
and then just to the soft lover moment
like I lived for I almost gonna wished
she started with lover and then built it
up to tea you need to calm down but
whatever I don't care was the first time
she performed love her live you could
tell like the people in the audience
like we're excited like they respect her
like everyone knew the words it was
really impressive
and I want to talk about something I
want to talk about Queen Latifah you
know I'd like live for Queen Latifah and
like hurry and I think with John
Travolta last night you know he's
problematic well just like we let the
hairspray dream he was being really
funny yeah except he's [ __ ]
problematic and wise nobody talking
about it
but Queen Latifah when she was listening
to love her
they caught to her for a minute and she
was making this face she was like like
she was here for the first time she was
like damn this is good but people on
Twitter we're taking the screen shot of
her just like this like Queen Latifah
hates Taylor and it's like no she
[ __ ] doesn't I'm living for the
moment of watching and like people this
is just further proof that people on
Twitter literally ruin every they had
the same thing of DJ Kyle doing the
exact same movement right he's like yeah
honestly it's a really new song that
came out like two weeks ago I don't know
if dj khaled has heard it yet it's like
he was listening to it for the first
time he's like in it I agreed that lover
was was wonderful beautiful and you know
it's not like it made me love the song
even me too incredible job and I
actually thought that it might have been
more powerful if she just did that like
woman in her underwear and her guitar
and her blazer singing her heart out
because but she had to saying you need
to calm down cuz it was a song that was
nominated for everything I guess like I
do see that but it just it was also like
they only did half the song like it was
kind of just half-ass right because it's
the opening it needs to be like good
Betty you know but I hear you it would
have been cool to really focus on lover
yeah for sure but then can we please
talk about the Cosmo article because I
sat here yesterday saying that like
Cosmo magazine like thinks it's cool to
each other so if they just like write
negative things about her so after her
performance they wrote an article being
like so many people are you know calling
out Taylor Schmidt for lip-syncing and
I'm very aware of lip-syncing and I
didn't notice anything about Taylor
maybe I'm like okay my horse blinders
are on and they literally you read this
article they found like six people on
Twitter who like thought she was
lip-syncing and just like made it into
an article like when well that's
I know it got me so mad because then I
watch the whole show and literally a
little na sax was the worst slip sinker
I mean I love him and I don't care but
like okay we're gonna call people out
she didn't lip-sync she had a back track
which she does sometimes but she was had
her mic on loan on sex take not happens
my god neither judge nor money and
honestly neither did Missy Elliott for
some parts yeah we call anybody
let's call everyone out I'm so sick of
this double standard by the way also if
you just listen to the first line and
lover that she's saying she's picky as
hell yeah also you need to come down
there in a couple parts shooting sounds
so good so I hope that wasn't exactly
okay very fair oh I just I'm so [ __ ]
over Cosmo and the girl who wrote it for
Cosmo is the same girl who wrote all the
other nasty things about Taylor look
what did Taylor do to even high school
girlfriend I don't know I'm tell you're
totally right you definitely just said
no to a Cosmo cover yes something like
that
totally but can we do also talk about
like the cliques because we had this
celebrity section of 20 celebs who
showed up to the show who had their own
stage and refused to like dance to move
it was the weirdest didn't get over and
like I was seeing him like that's how it
should be don't let all the celebrities
in one section all the important moments
are happening on the stage right in
front of them like people take they're
having so much fun they were all
drinking champagne like Halsey and the
daddy sisters Trio trio I love that it
was just a weird mix of subs because the
more the night went on I realized how
many connections ever though there's I
agree that it's every joke I was like oh
everyone's cool now cuz taylor loves
Game of Thrones on says cheering her on
but then I realized her at the end of
the night oh my god GG and Joe are like
two rows away from each other and you
know what like I rush I know everyone's
moved on but like I haven't moved on and
therefore they it was so real it was
like such an adult relationship it's
like the type of love where we're over
it but I just never want to see you
again
no I I couldn't agree more and he's with
his new way and like she looked they but
I mean Sansa looks amazing but Gigi and
I just looked slamming so lemon and
there was like a lot of talk about our
Bellas outfit I thought she looked
[ __ ] amazing and I didn't mind the
blond hair people like blood no lives
for it they both like monochromatic
whatever they were doing vibes living
for it they looked like Johnny
supermodels like I which they are they
brought everything they had like to New
Jersey it was crazy and I appreciate
that because New Jersey definitely
needed it halsy red carpet outfit was
one of the worst they've ever seen
and then she put on the most beautiful
six stunning dress that she wore the
entire time that was just like a skirt
and a crop top that was like connected
on the side and I don't know why she did
wear that on the red car because she
looked [ __ ] sick and she was up there
with the Hadid sisters and she was
fitting in yeah the Hadid sisters were
having a good time but there it was so
there weren't that many celebs there no
they had literally one section yeah so
then like there was Diplo there was
Queen Latifah there was bebe Rexha bebe
Rexha know and also like Jesse Tyler
Ferguson yeah being sitting right behind
Taylor Swift like there was something
weird because he was in the loading bay
party and Camilla timeö and Shawn Mendes
and he was just like holding her up just
so she wouldn't bother yeah I thought
she was fun she looked like a good time
I actually really liked her yeah I liked
her too
there's a dog in the studio and it's
right not - it's her - look hi doggy
anyway okay back to performances best
performance of the night what do you
think
okay well couch ugh what's in your eat
oh sure it was it was special you know
like it was after seeing that
Entertainment Weekly article that
accidentally came out about them bla bla
bla I entertain me tonight by the way
justice James I couldn't help but just
think like how orchestrated this entire
thing was um but I was like a living for
it except like the cringy kisses and
like the mouth breathing
I was just wondering like does her
breath smell and like how you know that
smell and you like from a Hey oh my god
you guys stop treating her like she's an
alcoholic she's fun if you and I went to
an award show I did go to an award show
and I blacked out no it's cool like once
in a while but if you're the person
who's drunk at every award show I don't
know and you sound like fun I don't know
oh it never actually there were four
mints make you believe more or less in
their lives yeah and we were we stood
here on the show about a month ago being
that we believed in their love and then
that Entertainment Tonight um articles
just really threw a wrench and all that
and now I've just been like
second-guessing their body language as a
body language expert as the in-house
body language expert and then this
contrived [ __ ] performance was just
awful and I'm really surprised because
when Shawn Mendes did that Haley Bieber
thing he swore he would like never do
anything like that again he said in his
book article like he felt so stupid but
here he is doing it again a book makes
me think that he's not
you know like which is that it has to be
real but like it's so not real it's
crazy it's so not real it's crazy and
just everyone like playing along like
did you see all the reactions I'm like
Joe Jonas and Sophie they were like
dying
Taylor was died everyone's like playing
along they know it's not real I don't
need that that makes it a little real
why would they all be acting as if this
is some elaborate like that everyone
wants to be involved in do you know what
I mean
like why would everyone be doing that I
don't know I don't know there's
something not right about it that's all
I'll say that the I I would agree with
that
okay whatever they're also Camilla's
white dress that she wore on the carpet
was awful
I missed it she's literally like in the
prime in the words of Monica gotta move
on
she's in the prime of life like she's
never been more on top she's [ __ ]
snatch and this dress was just like so
not it it was really bad it was bad it
was and then the one she and then she
changed back into it like I like when
someone wears something that I don't
like Halsey but then she changed into
something else say why did Camila have
any other rapid changes she changed at
least once for her performance change
into something cute I went to her for
her performance he's lovely she change
into anything after that
it was a bomb thought it was cute and
then it but because she obviously like
was a little drunk like it just it
looked it was a messy dress that wasn't
helping him at one point I thought we
were gonna see this match allure yes
okay my favorite performance that we've
gone too long without talking about was
Liz oh one thousand literally full-body
chills and there were a few moments
where last night where some of these
aren't like Lisa was up for Best New
Artist and she was robbed
she's [ __ ] showed up but like there's
once in a while where an artist performs
and like sometimes just happened with
like Demi Lovato I remember what she was
saying like when she did a prince
tribute or like when ariana grande
performed at the Grammys the first time
like where people realize like how
talented a person is and I feel like
everybody knows how talented this always
but this like was a huge moment for her
like she sounded incredible the whole
like the visuals and the vibe of the
performance was incredible and her
message was so amazed do you see her
Instagram stories no when she said sorry
her Instagram post can I read it she oh
sure it was I just love her so much
and okay hold that it was like really
all about her dancers so she said let me
just get to the bottom because it's
super long
being a big black woman with y'all by my
side is the honor of my life and I hope
this moment stays forever between you
titties honestly and you know what it's
like people I think the the cool thing
about Liz though it's like there's so
many sides to her like okay she has the
best music like you can't tell me that
that song good as hell is not the best
song ever like her music really speaks
for itself and then when she performs
you're like so shook to see like her
voice is incredible like watch her um
NPR tiny did I watch it oh my god like
she has just such range and like she's
so sick like her voice is amazing and
then her entire brand has like this
amazing message of self-love like
there's so she never stops amazing me oh
yeah I realize like the world has been
turned on to Chile's Oh for like months
and I'm like super late to the party and
I'm just trying to make up for it and
we're just happy to be here we're just
happy to be here like I just [ __ ]
stad Liz out like to death and I can't
believe that she didn't win I can't
believe they had someone win Best New
Artist who was wasn't there I was really
in shock I end up with the entire mtv
promo like every commercial I've seen
for MTV VMAs Bob Bob Bob Bob yeah was
that stupid Billy Eilish song there was
obviously some sort of Scooter Braun
agreement background behind the scenes
is Scooter Braun rat Billy Eilish does
he know I don't know but also like she
won best push artist before the award
show even started so I thought that was
their way of giving what fresh push best
push artists see like that's what I mean
when I feel old I don't even know what
the category means yet but I know that
Hayley kiyoko won it last year so like
it's somewhat prestigious yes for sure
but like I don't even know what it means
Diplo is just so like I just like ship
like I just ship him like with himself
do you know what I mean like he I don't
even know what to call him cuz he's like
really an influencer he's a DJ he's just
a comedian it's different business card
says Oh Diplo like international man of
mystery
totally attorney-at-law yeah that's
Diplo Esquire everyone needs a business
card if I went to the VMAs and I was
ever prestige enough to sit in the
celebrity sir should I be handing that
[ __ ] out left and [ __ ] right miss
different users only carefully selected
inks and responsibly sourced paper
Stotts
they have dozens of designs that are
right just for your business you can
upload your own design if you're
creative like that but if you know you
know your limits you can use one of
their designs that are super cute and
fancy you can add your logo and contact
information with just a few clicks and
you can use it on all your marketing
going
your satisfaction with this print is
100% guaranteed or they'll make it right
either by reprinting your order or
refunding in your order vistaprint wants
you to be able to own the now in any
situation which is why our listeners
will get 500 high quality custom
business cards starting with a nine
dollar starting at $9.99 use code toast
at vistaprint.com that's code TOA st at
vistaprint.com toast at vistaprint.com
love it two more things I want to talk
about before we move on first Missy
Elliott's video Vanguard performance was
incredible I didn't even realize how
many [ __ ] bangers Missy Elliott had
because every single one of her songs
still plays in the club like it's a new
song no it's so good the whole
performance was amazing she brought out
Alyson Stoner which was just like the
king oh my god and I forgot that Alyson
Stoner girl realistic video as a dancer
as the girl in Missy Elliott's which
song I forgot in one of her music videos
and that's how she really got started
like it was just it was a lot it was not
all kind of sodor it a lot and then she
was in the Pepsi commercial what she
yeah
donar breaking it assets Turner knows a
lot oh yeah oh yeah baked it she is a
she is a locked up was about my
knowledge yeah for sure
but it was great to see her it was great
to see her also just talking about sour
Larsen like Terrence J when they had
like two more minutes before the show
actually started and they were talking
about what they were excited what's your
favorite Missy Elliott sucked she goes
there's just so many you know every
question he asked her she was like I
want them all to him it was it was so
great it was painful it was painful but
I really liked her last night they put
like a big emphasis on on dancing you
know that's important to me yes and I
think it's important to VMAs because
Video Music it's like all about visuals
mm oh and then we have to talk about the
weird Marc Jacobs of it all and they
they did him dirty they cut it off and
then they come back from a commercial
break and he's saying they know what's
really crazy when he spoke to her and
Shay and like testing the one question
he launched him to like a speech that he
had written clearly for him and I was
like what are you gonna say for your
speech turns out he did get a speech
right good thing he said it on the red
carpet no honestly I had no idea who it
was until like they were showing him on
the red carpet on my like Genki little
backstage feed and I was like
it's this guy wise everyone likes like
like giving him so much time and
attention and I guess he just his hair
doesn't always look like that so I think
I just didn't recognize him with his new
hair yeah that was just so odd it was
just so long they were throwing so much
[ __ ] into it it was crazy it's like just
they just needed to get people over from
New York to New Jersey and they were
like let's get the fashion people you
know and I just I'm curious what why it
was done in New York I don't know feel
like I died somewhere recently that New
Jersey is gonna is starting to give tax
breaks to people who film there like an
Atlanta sort of thing so I went last
year to the Radio City and it was like
it was just like small do you know yeah
that's too small but they could have
done MSG
yeah no I didn't done Citi field's it
makes a lot of image sense like how much
easier it probably was just like load in
load how build in New Jersey like doing
[ __ ] in the city is just impossible and
so expensive so I kind of understand
that I thought maybe they would do it at
Barclays Center in Brooklyn like that
that would be great and that's like a
cool Prudential Center
it's like lame as [ __ ] like it took
embarrassing to perform that's where I
started to McGraw no I really think that
there's tax incentives to go to New
Jersey and by the way that would be the
only reason that makes sense yeah and it
does make sense but like how much
traffic you think they all have to say
then going and coming I know and then
the after-party was in Times Square
right are they choppering people in and
out
they definitely choppered the Jonas
Brothers unless actually Jonas Brothers
was pre filmed yesterday yeah toasters
were there I saw Joe Jonas is no Joe
Jonas is coming and tuxedo yesterday
that's so annoying
and it doesn't make sense because they
easily could have done it last night I
thought they're on tour and they weren't
gonna make it to the VMAs you had to do
what ed Sheeran doesn't everyone okay he
just like choppers in his own concert
they just live streaming his concert
yeah yeah like but actually that the
Jonas Brothers performance was really
cool like we've all standing in the
parking lot with all those people around
them I was like how are people not like
jumping them like they really were like
there was no barricade between like the
fans and like people were getting in
their way they were trying to come
through and like Nick and Joe were
literally shoving each other out of the
way so they could get to the front yes
annalee blaming the best point they
probably took the ferry soldiers
sponsored by C Street I
I thought the performance was really
good and that looked so fun like I
thought the new BMA's was a shitshow
production - but that concert them on
the pier like with the Sun setting and
all the fireworks like that was [ __ ]
beautiful and I wish I was there yeah
also it was in Asbury Park which is
where we just were we could have been
there Priyanka wasn't there no it's when
they open when they an award and they
were all kissing each other Nick Jonas
like just stood there I know I fell down
a rabbit hole is like Nick Jonas
trending on Twitter I was sending you
guys meetings on where's my so fun the
Jonas Brothers fans now that they're
like old they're hilarious and they just
like making memes about the Jonas
Brothers and they were so funny and so
weird but I guess there were some my
least shippers there last night because
Miley single she was there Nick was
there without Priyanka
oh also I have to make a rebuttal no
I've said on the show that I really
pride myself on being the type of person
who knows when they're wrong you can own
their mistakes and I feel as though I
might have jumped the gun and saying
Miley Cyrus isn't a singer because she
was really [ __ ] up I think and she is
a person who literally saying without a
backtrack and that completely raw and
for a second I thought it was pre-taped
because it was in this weird filter I
didn't see any fans but then they zoomed
out at the end and she was in fact
onstage and then I saw like pictures of
her backstage and she was wearing that
little black dress she looked amazing
she sounded amazing and I take back
everything I said okay we appreciate
that we appreciate her mettle here and I
agree she was incredible she was oh also
as a show they Shaggy
went when we were decoding her lyrics
when she says she wants her house in the
hills that's not the house that burned
down her house in Malibu the house that
burned down yeah is that or the hills in
Malibu did Hollywood Hills is like I
think it's like in LA but then she's
going back to the city lights yeah cuz
she's go back to the city lights where
the hair is nice it's you so no music I
just don't know enough about Ellie's
typography yeah hagh Rafi okay
are we off are we done with the VMAs oh
and then rumors were swirling the GG and
Tyler C went to the octave Rd together
but still there's not one professional
photo of them together so I don't give a
[ __ ] you get B to like I don't report
news just because someone's publicist
gave it to e news no but also they've
been together every day for like the
last three weeks so like we don't report
every day that they were together I want
to see a photo of them together
I'm Cindy Holliday Steve tweeted that he
got info right before the red carpet
started that Tyler was coming as Gigi's
date I plot so like I was like are you
[ __ ] kidding me
and then it turns out not to meet you he
said sorry I misread my
my Intel it's actually the after party
they're going to together neither of
which have actually been confirmed so
the job reality scene that's not it for
you today no I was freaking out when I
thought that was gonna be true but I'm
glad that it wasn't no I'm sorry like I
have worked too hard to meet Taylor
Swift just have Tyler see just stumble
in no but also like Joe shows up with
the Queen of the north and you show up
with that just sorry people I Jackie
that is such a great [ __ ] point like
but hey I just that's such a great call
but I just reminded me did anyone feel
like something was off with in the Jonas
family last night yes yeah once I was
reading all these memes on Twitter about
how there's all this underlying beef um
yes they just seemed like unhappy and
Kevin didn't hug Sophie you know what I
was thinking about also he hug his wife
obviously and then Nick and Joe but why
just why gloss over so so Federer that
doesn't like shake me as crazy and
considering all the anti Julian
commercials do you think they didn't
allow Sophie don't turn into jewel on TV
or they weren't broadcasting it they
wouldn't allow it
there was a camera on the audience the
entire time oh yeah then I'd like to
that by the way they have that like
digital you be able to see who you
wanted to stream yeah and so I didn't
see any footage of her Julian may be
like you just keep cutting tool like in
the or Cho maybe Bryce like I don't
think you can actually Joel in a stadium
I feel like she was drooling at the B be
amazed like she had it in hand she
definitely was but she wasn't I mean the
B be amazed were also something to think
about you know the B be amazed were like
the Jonas Brothers show like this at
first row I thought the seating was
really weird to join us mother we're
like the fifth row but like the fifth
row of what nobody really trying to do
but why was Jesse Ferguson ahead of the
Joe gross right I think it's just that
CD seat world where you got up you lose
your seat someone takes it no no I saw
that celebrities have reserved seats I
know I want to be in the front row like
to have it all the attention on you like
maybe I need to suspend if you think
about it logistically Gigi was like
front to the left so if they were front
front they're right next to each other
no no like that was super far back like
there was three rows of nobodies before
the Jonas Brothers and they needed their
own row so like I don't know I just
thought like they're stars yeah no I
think they wanted a little bit of like
privacy you know maybe they want any
load the camera on them
entire time okay and technically you
can't like jewel indoors but right
people do so everyone does
okay next door is this here I've had and
I'm truly excited okay
Kim Kardashian has come up with a new
name for her solution Merline and it is
called skims solution where and I love
it it's such a great name because it
sounds like skin her name is Kim and
they're like skimpy little items love it
and I released more pictures of the
actual items and there's so many things
I'm going to get that broad like the
relaxation Rob the Spanx undies sorry
skin undies I'm actually very excited
for this business venture and I hope it
succeeds I love this leotard that she's
wearing like her breasts looks so supple
and no but everyone's here like I mean
it should be called supple obviously
there's you know probably Photoshop now
Blake everyone looks like they're being
skimmed right no no I'm really excited
about this and she had a wide range of I
don't need to see like Spanx on a person
who doesn't ever need to wear space you
know they mean I would like to see a
real person wearing Spanx who might
actually wear them to work she has a
great variety of body types I'm looking
for mine I think I see me let me see if
I could see me wait well actually this
would be a bad game like I was gonna say
what do you think is me but you know I
do not want to know but I think I think
yeah for sure for sure um also like I
was thinking about it this is her
billion dollar yes sure like this is
where she either becomes a billionaire
or she does purchase us up no or she
just goes back to her perfumes and
whatnot but um this is the billion
dollar bed
I agree like this is the this is what's
gonna make her long-term family money
yeah this is her Kylie cosmetics right
it's crazy that Kylie cosmetics must be
so much more successful than k'kaw
beauty if Kylie's a billionaire in Kim's
I got 300 million air no I know but also
I think Kim's 300 million Eric doesn't
have a lot to do with k'kaw beauty but
that's crazy
she made a hundred million dollars from
that app remember that's crazy to think
about that like Kylie cosmetics is that
of course it's bigger than K ki w ET but
it's ten times the size yeah no I just I
I'm I'm a Kardashian obsessed like I
will buy anything but I just don't [ __ ]
with k'kaw Beauty like at all I don't
know if it's just like not
for me but none of the lipstick on there
that I would actually wear I bought one
lipstick and it was so not what it
appeared to be online it was like this
like this mauve like my regular color
and it like was rose red like it was it
was just insane I just I don't know what
it is like the coloring the packaging
it's just not for me I thought was kinky
w body though I wonder found a lot of
money haven't gotten it like I still
haven't been able to get the one that I
want I have this shimmer but I don't
have the founding oh I use it all the
time I have the pound nation and I don't
think I need it I think I need the
shimmer okay maybe we kind of never got
the brush so I wasn't able to use any of
it but I put some of the the foundation
on my like it's just like so thick and
like I don't need that you actually do
like sometimes about me for me like I'm
about to go out with like a crusty white
leg and it's not gonna work so I don't
care how to stain everything in my path
right it's not gonna put on foundation
if you go to a white party
you can't wear it no but and if it's
something like this summer everyone's
decently tan it doesn't matter but
sometimes like I have to put on pants
because my legs look so terrible and
that's what it's for
that's what do I use the okw foundation
all the time so I wonder when this comes
out scams
I'm really I think I hope it's not like
drops like it should be like a real
business that always said it has
inventory and one I can get whatever I
want you know yeah I'm really excited
like this is something I really need I
think it will be like that because drops
is like a very trendy thing but solution
where does not try it's not trendy but
this is a sustainable long yeah it is
I'm wearing this dress with a slit and I
need this undergarment now I think
she'll I think she knows what she's
doing
okay next story SNL announces their fall
lineup including some of people's
favorite people September 28th we have
host Woody Harrelson who I love musical
guest Billy Eilish October 5th we had
the Phoebe Waller bridge with musical
guest Taylor Swift
Phoebe Waller bridge is from fleabag
hailey it's like everyone she's like the
it girl of the moment and I'd never
heard of her maybe I have never heard of
her and I didn't do a quick Google
search
October 12th host David Harbor musical
guest Camila Cabello November 2nd host
Kristen Stewart no musical guest yeah
December 21st host
Murphy Oh Eddie Murphy that's gonna be
like iconic anyone he knows
November 2nd or December 21st it should
be Luke Holmes musical guest because he
has his album coming out imagine you
should let his manager announcement by
the way someone was saying familiar
manager to a manager oh yeah I could do
that um for Taylor's swar imagine if
they had if she hadn't laid open I saw
that too I would die I would die but
anyway also I feel is okie to SNL yeah
yeah it's just about like who has new
music and who's like around yeah oh
these people are on tour Billie Eilish
is on tour in Russia
she's that's what she said in her video
this is so huge it's so it's crazy I
went down the rabbit hole of her
Instagram the other day and like she
posts videos she has this like thing of
like having her huge audience become
like a mosh pit like they all run in
circles in a line it's a whole thing
that's what Ben does when he goes to
concerts okay so that's they do Nazis a
little deep like that they're her age is
pretty young and it's crazy it's
ginormous and like just this whole
swarming thing nobody to watch she is
just like she's how old is she like 17
yeah it's crazy she's just like the same
age as Jojo see whoa yeah and they're
two totally different people but they're
both super tall something about belly is
as tall as your sort you saw it's like a
clothes right shoes right when I hide so
like elevators yeah I don't know but
anyways that's exciting I said Mel's
coming back we got some good hosts they
got really good musical guest yes really
prestigious who was the first one uh
Billie a douche oh yeah no that's that's
really good I feel like SNL has
maintained like their prestige when it
comes to musical artists it's like like
I feel like their viewership goes up and
down but like they always seem to get
like who's who of of the music industry
and I'm just looking forward to my time
singing toast you need like two more
songs and then you can go yeah how many
songs do you sing I think - I think -
too big very sad
okay next story something I'm so excited
about okay KFC is testing plant-based
Fried Chicken I saw and for some reason
I don't think this is it I like this is
my own [ __ ] I didn't had to impossible
burgers yesterday on his way home from
Maryland he said they're so [ __ ] good
from Burger King like he was like I
could have
three like he's send there my god you
need to get one I need to have when I'm
so excited for each let's Jordache them
the chicken list chicken options are
part of a collaboration with beyond meet
America's finger-licking good chicken is
going plant pace on Monday KFC announced
they have partnered with beyond me an
la-based producer of plant-based meat
substitutes to create a plant-based menu
option for KFC customers KFC beyond
fried chicken the vegan menu option will
be sold as chicken nuggets with the
customer's choice of dipping sauces or
boneless wings first it'll be available
in a store in Atlanta and Atlanta
toasters and you just snatch it all up
so that they go nationwide yes this is
so crazy like I love how it just
happened overnight like five years ago
there wasn't a single vegan or
vegetarian option at fast-food chains
now almost every single one will have
one yeah whether they're partnering with
beyond or impossible it's it's so
exciting I had to be on burger yesterday
for just regular restaurants in the city
have them man really it was amazing
but I really want to try the Big Mac one
like I feel like yeah let's do door -
lets do door - just what he just said
five seconds ago - here drink so sorry I
just wanna get Burger King so okay we'll
do it
okay he's looking only on door - yeah
like McDonald's is only uh no Brants oh
yes it is McDonald's have I don't think
we've reported about McDonald's should I
look it up doing any hunger King and
weed you know it's not good for them
yeah they gotta go - what are they it's
Burger King KFC who was being Duncan
don't Donald isn't using the plant-based
burger - menus may 13th - in 1900 it's
already there no this is just about the
articles written
okay so I would assume that's the
impossible whopper has got some
competition go ahead sue crazy honestly
Burger King really blew it out on this
one like they had they have the
commercial that's running well yeah but
also Dunkin Donuts is doing breakfast
sandwiches and it's just like we said
yesterday like competition is great for
the consumer as a consumer I'm here for
this competition like we're just getting
so many planned place options I'm just
gonna put a chamalla that's so lucky
yeah no we're still I'm gonna need to go
a serious diet after I test out all the
options it's great for the vegetarians
it's great for the kosher folk and it's
great for the environment yeah because
we're killing less animals
it's amazing sustainable incredible yeah
I've been then came home and he
over there he was gone for like a 24
hour road trip he had three impossible
burgers in the course of 36 hours I said
open that computer get on noon because
you're looking a little Celt you got it
you got a little spells specific book oh
it's felt not good it's about oh I
thought it was like whatever specific
goals you want to achieve not just
losing weight so taking care of yourself
working out is good obviously for losing
weight but there's just so many other
benefits to it better self care you can
feel more confident in your clothing you
have more energy and you've been overall
glow to you there's also a lot of
psychological benefits to working out
you're able to make healthy choices your
self-worth improves you're in a better
mood you can control your stress and
anxiety so Noom is a habit changing
solution that helps users learn to
develop a new relationship with food
through personalized courses based on
psychology Noom teaches you the way why
to do things the way why you do things
the way you do and arms you with the
tools to break the bad habits and
replace them with better ones
they say it's based on cognitive
behavioral approach we just say it works
new without a diet it's a healthy and
easy to stick to way of life no food is
good bad off limits new teaches
moderation and can be used in
conjunction with many preexisting
popular diets if you want one of the
biggest and most accurate food databases
available that lets you track meals
visualize portion sizes and see calorie
density at the glance we are all shut
for time new masks for just 10 minutes
of your day for yourself your human if
you go off track there's no shaming just
tips to help you get back on track for
tomorrow chat with the goal specialist
and new community to get and give chat
with your goal specialist and new
community to get and give help to people
going through the same exact thing you
don't have to change it all in one day
small steps to make progress sign up for
your fight for your trial today at noon
and oom dot-com slash toast what do you
have to lose visit new home slash toast
to start your trial today that's Noom
comm slash toast the last weight loss
program you need love it someone said we
should do a taste test for patron of all
the different I was thinking that this
morning that you guys should do one of
those like how much he really does that
for anything so what would what would we
get we would get mcdonalds burger we
would get burger king we would get um we
tuck it in we would get dunking we can't
get KFC yet
Subway's coming out with their
impossible meat sub wow I mean I don't
even like that [ __ ] so maybe you two
would do it because like I would rather
die than a mess
it's actually a really good yeah taste
tester it's just if you do a taste test
with Ben you'll never be able to look at
it the same again because this is what
he does so I'm gonna take a sip of water
but still I guess Somali an agenda to
tea goes like this disgusting okay these
and final story a little business a
little pharma news because I think this
is gonna be like it this is probably a
small story today actually it's a big
story but I just could see myself
watching it like in an episode of
American greed next year so I just want
to be on top of it okay because I keep
watching American greeting them like all
these stories were happening and I miss
them all right you know but now that we
do the news like we can highlight
stories right like Enron like Enron like
tell tell X have you ever that was what
I was talking about that big fraud that
um it was like an what's MLM oh and in
fields they got three over three billion
dollars yeah it's really sad and it
happened like just a few years ago it's
like where was I anyways Oklahoma opioid
of ruling gives green light for other
lawsuits
while some Johnson & Johnson investors
were relieved at the company's 570 $2
million penalty 572 million dollar
penalty for fueling Oklahoma's opioid
crisis wasn't as high as feared lawyers
for other US state cities and counties
could hardly contain their glee so today
Johnson & Johnson has been fined 572
million dollars for their role in the
opioid crisis what is her role producing
opioids I guess Johnson & Johnson mix
company they're up there and everything
coming like they make they're like
everything they make the drug ass I
guess so they make Khal Drogo's that's
really my Oklahoma judged had Balkman
its had starters watching hey on Monday
was the first affirmation in court of a
high risk legal strategy using public
nuisance laws to punish predatory drug
marketing since the predatory you drug
marketing that they're being fined for
more than 45 other states in two
thousand local governments are hoping to
win billions of dollars in verdicts with
the same arguments Johnson & Johnson has
been through like many a scandal these
days but they're just like trying to be
this like wholesome family company
I know but also like I saw commercial
and actually Anna or spray Tanner told
me that she uses Burt's Bees baby powder
because
Johnson & Johnson baby powder has talcum
powder in it and so many people have
gotten breast cancer and ovarian cancer
from the talcum powder and baby Johnson
& Johnson's baby powder Shh
yeah like they have [ __ ] problems over
there they have problems and is leading
to an opioid crisis now this is gonna be
a dumb question
what is it opioid is it a pill yeah it's
like pain pills yeah it's a big problem
people are getting addicted and doctors
and and drug companies are over
prescribing them for having two people
who don't need them giving them too many
and then they become reliant on so
explain though how Johnson & Johnson is
involved in actually helping make the
opioid problem worse yes this is this is
a good um this is a good question okay
then I will look to what they just
manufacture it I I think so I guess I
don't really know what Johnson and
Johnson does let me find out yeah they
manufacture it but so why is there that
their fault because they're
manufacturing it just seems like we're
pointing the finger in the wrong
direction but I'm sure there's more to
it that I don't understand also they're
probably 90 factoring so many then
they're you know actually I don't know
the legalities but I could think that
maybe that now there's so many opioids
out there and if there was less woods
out there it's a hardware to opioids out
there people wouldn't be getting
prescribed so many yeah but like they
just manufacture based on demand it's
not their fault uh I don't know but they
created the demand perhaps someone is I
did lay back in the comments says
Johnson and Johnson makes money when a
doctor didn't finish the sentence but
I'm assuming he's gonna say prescribes
opioids paying dots to prescribe opioids
criminal they push doctors to prescribe
more and more every year they tell their
sales reps to push it and they do a lot
of lobbying for Big Pharma [ __ ] big
pharma fed up Wayne Oh Big Pharma
[ __ ] Big Pharma it's really like
watchin American green episodes about
pharmaceutical industry and it's really
hard to wrap your head around so I feel
like people don't even know what goes on
because it's like what the hell are they
even doing you know I don't know and
like they just use big words and like
lots of small writing that no one knows
like what's really going on
yeah let me tell you something about the
fine bread it's not so fun no it's
nothing
it's problematic and it's taking middle
America by the nutsack ya know so I
watched an American food episode about
these kids who were selling opioids at
their college and at one point in
Florida there were more opioids being
prescribed in Florida than in the whole
country you said those times did I say
this on the show yeah you just said it
to you guys I haven't heard it say it
again I'm literally having philosophy
looking at you know what I'm having a
flashback up here and you said as I was
sitting in this chair really yes again
okay at one point like a few years ago
there were more opioids in Florida than
in the whole country combined times 10
Wow that ain't right you know it's just
really sad you know I don't - yeah it is
really sad it's sad period I just like
okay it's like John - the Johnson salts
are making it pushing it but like people
are also taking it like but wait doctor
prescribes it - you don't think that
it's like necessary your that your
druggie I know it just feels like it's
fine but it's yeah but what about when
they run out the doctors prescribe it
again also I don't know yes also um the
society the what's the kid's name who
doesn't look like his name Tyler Harry
is he taking opioids I believe he's
taking opioids okay I don't know yet
because it's like a big white pill and
that's what the pill looks like if any
crushes that have been white circle
that's gonna be an interesting thing
that they tackle is like drug addiction
in the new world because they run out
eventually
he's gonna run out of druggie they grow
drugs or make it in a lab or maybe like
in that one pharmacy there's enough for
just Henry to get high for the rest of
his life no because now the rest of your
life like that's so much white how many
how many years days like what's a couple
thousand pills they might have that in a
pharmacy in a big town no I think he
needs more than a thousand pills to be
like a drug addict for the rest of his
life he's taken like five of it anyway
so then eventually even if the pills run
out like they're gonna have to deal with
drug addiction in the town where they
don't have the resources to do so
or maybe they'll run out and then hurry
we'll have to stop it well yeah when he
stopped taking drugs that's when he was
depressed and in
he's been the whole time it's like it's
withdrawal yeah yeah that's just part of
what it is recovering recovery that's
what happens in orange is a new plaque
like all the girls get so sick when red
makes them stop drinking or stop doing
drugs and they all like throw up and
shakes but it eventually like you get
you miss me and then you feel so much
better and I actually think there's
drugs for withdrawal which is if you're
trying to get off drugs but very sad Wow
I don't know if I've ever been
prescribed an opioid it sounds like it's
so common I've gotten a surgery or I got
my neck oh maybe then no no I got um I
got like one vicodin I got a joke Odom
when I got my wisdom teeth out is that
an opioid or opioids okay it's a hard
word to say are opioids called opioids
or they have like fancy names they have
different fancy names like oxy and then
there's another one that's like Cody
Roxie Cody Cody and hydrocodone ox ox e
morphine
you should flush fentanyl I don't have
like yha right but someone's thing it
only takes five days to get addicted
they give you like 30 pills some doctors
over prescriptions I see I see a chart
there because should you buy Johnson and
Johnson because they're making too many
well stop [ __ ] making them that's why
they didn't find five years company
their commercials are like Etsy Johnson
family it's like little baby tissues and
then they're like funding the opioid
problem I'm understanding now I have to
go that's why it's a big deal what
freaks yeah it's gotta stop where is
Johnson I want to talk to them and the
other one too right they're brothers
yeah for sure just recalled Jonas and
Jonas rebrands okay well thanks for
catching me up on the opioid problem
sorry I didn't know much about it but
sounds like it's very treacherous and no
bueno so shame on you tisk tisk Johnson
and Johnson yeah beginning March
bachelor in paradise
so we'll be because of the VMAs we're
gonna catch up tonight watch tonight and
then also do the snatch alert tomorrow
the snatchler is back up on iTunes but
we did lose all of our reviews and our
subscriptions so head over to this
snatchler on iTunes leave us a review
subscribe Spotify remains unchanged but
thank you for your patience we apologize
the
such drama snatch the snatcher right
back up right where you left her
I'm sorry also don't flush pills
apparently it's bad for the environment
so just bury them I guess light him on
fire or just oh I'm in the trash pull
out of the trash wow I didn't even know
I don't know that either they're in so
much hair uh animates me we'll see you
guys tomorrow have a great day thank you
you